[Music]
a leaf and debris vacuum automatically
collects all types of Fallen
debris instead of spending hours raking
this device quickly does it all making
yard work easier than
ever a leaf and debris vacuum is powered
by a gas or diesel engine the engine
spins an impeller which creates the
suction and also shreds the
leaves the machine is comprised of about
100 different parts all cut from .11 in
thick sheets of Steel using this
computer guided punch
press this part is the rear flange for
the impeller
[Music]
housing to make the sidewall of the
housing called the wrap a technician
bends this steel strip with a pinch
roller
[Music]
another technician positions the wrap on
the rear
flange and Tack welds them
[Music]
together the Craftsman places the
housing's front flange on top of the
wrap aligns its notches with wraps tabs
and Tack welds the parts
together
[Music]
he completes the housing with this
rectangular
[Music]
piece the shredded leaves exit the
housing through this
opening next the parts are placed on a
rotary Welding Table and the tack joints
are welded together the fused seams
ensure the housing is
airtight a computer guides this fiber
optic laser cutter slicing out the
impeller blades from a sheet of abrasion
resistant steel this steel is four times
thicker than the steel used for the body
[Music]
parts each impeller has four blades with
sharp edges that help Shred the
[Music]
leaves the welder mounts the impeller
components onto a
fixture each blade has a line tabs which
fit into notches on a backing plate
after clamping each blade in position he
fuses them to the backing
[Music]
plate next he welds steel reinforcement
straps between each of the four blades
the straps add strength and stability
thereby increasing the lifespan of the
[Music]
impeller
the technician completes the assembly by
bolting a compression Hub to the center
The Hub holds the engine crankshaft
together which rotates the
impeller then he inserts a simulated
crankshaft and tightens the compression
[Music]
Hub he places the impeller on this
machine to balance it since the impeller
can spin at a speed of more than 3 ,000
revolutions per minute this step is
critical for the machine to run
smoothly to maintain stability the
welder adds beads of weld to the lighter
side until the impeller
balances then he removes the simulated
[Music]
crankshaft meanwhile an assembler mounts
the 29 horsepower gas engine to the
engine deck of the trailer frame the
crankshaft pokes through a hole in the
frame's face
plate he bolts the impeller housing
which has been painted to the face
[Music]
plate the technician installs the
impeller on the crankshaft with the
shear
key then he bolts a protective steel
cover plate and attaches everything
everything with a central
[Music]
bolt next he applies a brand decal on
the housing's front
cover and bolts the cover to the
housing when ready for use the debris
shoot the hose and the intake hes are
attached to the front
[Music]
end as this demonstration shows the
impeller can shred leaves into particles
small enough to be used as
compost mountain bike tires are true
Trailblazers specifically designed for
off-road riding wider than regular road
tires mountain bike tires have raised
knobs or lugs that add stability on
uneven terrain built to withstand the
trail these tires can handle it all
[Music]
when the rubber hits the dirt it's all
about control mountain bike tires are
designed to grip the ground and provide
traction
off-road first designers use a computer
model of a tire to simulate the effects
of different rubber compounds
construction begins with rubber
compounds being mixed together to create
parts of the tire ingredients include
synthetic and natural rubbers self and
other
chemicals rotating spiral blades break
down the materials friction from the
mixing Heats and softens them this
transforms the ingredients into a
dough-like rubber compound powerful
rollers squeeze the compound into thick
long sheets and Blades cut the rolled
rubber into narrow
strips then the rubber travels through
more rollers that squeeze it down to the
desired
thickness the rubber sheets land on a
cart ready for
use technicians incase steel bead wire
with one of these compounds the bead
wire is the part of the tire that
connects to the wheels Rim as steel wire
travels through an aperture the rubber
is extruded to form the
casing the machine delivers the bead
wire to a spinning
disc the disc winds the bead wire
shaping it into rings which fit to a
wheel
rim to maintain the diameter of the wire
the technician tapes the ends together
holding the shape until the next stage
of
production next rubber sheets with
varying characteristics enter an
extruder using heat and pressure the
extruder forces the rubber through dyes
this process merges their
characteristics into a single sheet this
sheet will be used to make the bicycles
tread the tread rubber travels through a
Channel of cool
water meanwhile rollers coat fabric with
rubber to make pies for the tire
casing a moving blade cuts it into
strips this rubber is naturally tacky so
the pieces can be easily
spliced the system feeds leads the
strips to the tire building
machine a skilled assembler wraps the
strips to the machine drum to form the
tire casing and splices the rubber where
the ends
meet next robots slide two wire beads
around the casing the ends of the drum
fold the sides of the casing over the
bead
wires the technician applies rubber
coated fabric to the bead wires
strengthening the area
the tread rubber is placed in the center
a roller applies pressure as the drum
spins to wind the tread around the
casing then the ends are pressed
together
manually and one more turn of the drum
secures the tread rubber to the
casing once vent holes have been cut in
the rubber it's over to an expanding
mold where the tire takes shape
[Music]
the technician inserts a rubber curing
bladder to maintain the shape of the
tire then he places the mountain bike
tires in curing molds these individual
molds will steam cook the tires Under
Pressure to further shape
them this process forms knobs and other
protrusions on the Tire surface that are
designed to grip a rugged
terrain like a big waffle iron this mold
has cooked and formed the mountain bike
tire the tire is then placed on a rack
to
cool next the bike tire under go a
durability test while a computer
measures rolling resistance that's the
energy lost when the tire rotates and an
indication of how easily the tire will
roll this mountain bike tire is now
cleared to travel off the beaten
path